today I'm very pleased to have with me
Sergey we'll get into that as a Catalan
name Sergey Martine who teaches Spanish
or is it Martin
no might be nothing Martine Sergey
Martine Spanish and it's we're gonna
talk about languages because it's very
interesting Sergey is a Catalan speaker
and of course a Spanish speaker from
Valencia we'll get into that which is a
bit of a variation of Catalan maybe
we'll find out and he lives in Prague
where of course they speak a language
it's only spoken by I don't know if it's
10 million people but we'll get into
that as well so Sergey welcome to my
channel and I want to talk about
languages with you hello thank you thank
you very much for having me here it's a
pleasure to me ok so let me first of all
ask you because a lot of people who
watch my channel study Spanish and so
and Spanish of course is a dominant
world language it's spoken by I don't
know 500 million a 500 milliwatts
and so then we have Catalan yeah which
is spoken by sorry on a European sort of
level it's not it's not an insignificant
language I mean there's like there's
more Catalan speakers and Finnish
speakers for example yeah yeah that's it
7 million or what's the number I didn't
know exactly because I and just a
speaker I just speak Valentino Catalan
whatever you you want to call it right
and I think it's between 7 and 9 million
okay exactly yes so the next question is
yeah so you look at the map and it says
they speak Catalan on the Balearic
Islands they speak Catalan in Valencia
then you read somewhere that the polenta
yeah no say no no it's not Catalan it's
something else and so what's this what's
the deal how similar are those languages
okay okay before we start
talking about these yeah we have to say
that some haters will come here to kill
me
whatever I say it's something very risky
talk now about this okay my point of
view how I learned it
I learned Catalan is the the name of the
language right and then we have
different variants variations of of
Catalan spoken maybe in Catalunya but
maybe in different parts of Catalunya is
different same happens in Valencia or in
Majorca right so the Catalan spoken in
in the Balearic Islands is called
Majorcan and the Catalan spoken in in
comunidad Valenciana is a real name of
the autonomy is Valentino but then some
years ago some politicians
I repeat is my point of view and
politicians came to add a language
called Valenciano because they created
an academy to study the balance the
Valencian language right I learned that
everything is Catalan we understand each
other perfectly no problem I've lived
for 10 years in Barcelona right and and
one year in in Majorca so so for you if
you speak to someone if you speak your
Valentino
and you think to someone from Corona yes
and someone from Majorca all of you no
effort no struggle you just communicate
yes maybe some small stuff we will have
a little bit of struggle but but nothing
nothing that could let us understand
each other no absolutely not and order
and order is the same right Endora it's
a it's something like special because
otherwise the only
the only country independent country
which whose if I can say that sorry my
that Catalan is the is the official
language the only official language of
the country so Catalan is spoken in in
Andorra and it's something very like
peculiar because here in Prague they
have a part of the of the University of
prac right where they teach Catalan and
it's sponsored but the government of
Andorra so here you can learn Catalan
for free I have a student of of Catalan
we do just a conversation but and I know
the teacher and my wife started studying
Catalan with with with this teacher
Andre and he teaches there and I went
there once just to say hello to the
school and it's nice you know we have
gone on that link we have cattle on the
link yes so yeah she should get your
wife on to cut to link study that many
stories in like I have not studied
Catalan how difficult would it be for me
to learn Catalan and would there be and
this is the other question we're talking
about say interference between similar
languages like I find yes that when I
speak Portuguese people complain that
I'm speaking poor - no because I speak
Spanish much much better than Portuguese
so that they have the Spanish it
controls my pronunciation in Portuguese
some of the words that I use it's very
difficult to keep it Portuguese so if a
person learns Catalan how easy or
difficult is it to keep the two
languages separate well I think the my
experience there are always interference
is it's absolutely normal and you have
to cope with it and that's it mmm but
the good thing is that they are not that
far away so you can learn one language
and quite easily quite fast you can
learn and start speaking fluently in
the other language right and you will
have interferences my my wife's example
we have lived for 12 years in Spain in
Catalan speaking places working wherever
and she still mixes sometimes some word
12 years living there and speaking
fluently when when she arrived so I mean
it's that's fast I mean yeah but you
know interference by guys I have done
business with say Germans and Swedish
people and there is interference from
their language in English because given
people who speak very very well Germans
will always say I have I have been
living in Canada since many years which
is incorrect you have to say for many
years yes right they do it and I can
sign similar examples in Swedish so even
people who are very fluent there's
always interference from other languages
it's once you enter more than one
language you're gonna have interference
you're gonna have errors you're gonna
have problems that's normal but I think
I think that the the point of view of
the modern language speaking and
learning is more like like open for
example in Catalan now it's more like
every single variation of the language
is accepted so the way I speak in my
town right in Valencia is very different
than the way that they speak in let's
say in menorca and the balearic islands
absolutely different but both are
correct are right right yeah so so I
mean we can make some some changes we
even in in my Valentino in my Catalan we
have some interferences from from
Spanish so a foreign speaker I mean it's
absolutely acceptable that he can make
some interferences and there is no
problem with that if the communication
is ok and you can understand for me no
problem now what about the to what
extent do people who live in areas where
call it a minority it's not a minority
language but lesser it's not even lesser
but languages with fewer speakers ok so
ok
do people in Barcelona for
or for that matter non Catalans who live
in Barcelona do they take the trouble to
learn Catalan if they arrive I'm not
talking about somebody went to school
there a Spanish person say who who was
born there went school there but someone
who arrives from Madrid to Barcelona is
he gonna bother learning Catalan in
general well there is a problem and it's
a political conflict there is a
political conflict political problem and
it's not easy to get rid of these
politics but I think once you get rid of
these politics there is absolutely no
problem
I have many foreigners many friends who
don't speak a word of Catalan and they
have been living for not since four
years right maybe 15 years in Barcelona
not speaking a word of of Catalan
absolutely no problem with that but it's
true there is a political issue and I
need it's like I mean but but it happens
if you go to to Madrid and you are
Catalan you could have problems with
somebody like narrow-minded or but every
Catalan speaker speaks Spanish but not
every Spanish speaker in Barcelona speak
Catalan that's it so so it would be
there for the it would be the exception
if someone can say a businessman moves
to Barcelona for his work yeah
or her work it's it's the exception that
they would go to the trouble of learning
Catalan yes or what yes so they would go
to the store the shopkeeper let's say
and they would just speak Spanish and
the shop speaking shopkeeper will reply
in Spanish how about in in Prague like
in the Czech Republic
you have foreigners who live there the
foreign community there do they bother
learning Czech yes yes they do but they
don't need it I mean here I mean you are
in the I see the geographical center
same
of Europe right so it's a country we're
here live like ten and half million of
inhabitants so and Europe is has like
three hundred millions of in our control
right so they have to learn another
language if they want to communicate
with the majority of their surrounding
right so here is very accepted and very
usual that people speak English or
another language so I have friends
living here who speak like check let's
say that they know they can say
absolutely laying a sentence in check
and they live and they get along and
absolutely yeah yeah yeah but speaking
the language is something very different
I mean it's a it's a step forward I did
something that helped me a lot so I
started coming coming here with my with
my girlfriend right she's my wife and I
met her friends family in English some
in in Spanish and after a couple of
years I came back and I started using my
first words in check so they were
surprised like wow said gee you can
speak chair you can say four words like
I need a beer or something like that I
need to go to the toilet anything
correct need to learn more and more so
for me it was like wow my ego and
skyrocket is so important so Sergey you
of course you're located in Prague and
you teach Spanish online
Sergi Martin Spanish and your audience
is your audience is both in Prague but
also presumably around the world because
you're on the internet and we're gonna
leave a link to your channel but tell us
a bit about your methodology what you
offer on your channel and so forth yeah
okay in my channel they offer lesson
Spanish lessons
mostly on the street or while when when
I'm traveling so I like to to have some
context while teaching something so my
idea is okay I am here I'm doing this
stuff and how can i connect this stuff
to teach something in in Spanish this is
when you are travelling in space
whatever whatever whatever I go have
lessons in in Iceland
I have lessons in in Cyprus in India I
have several lessons in India for
example I want to go to Canada yeah okay
but you're speaking to Spaniards no you
speaking Spanish some time off so maybe
yeah in Istanbul in Istanbul I was
looking for spanish-speaking people and
I interviewed them but just that for
example I don't know once it was raining
in India yeah and I wanted to say an
expression we use like it is a stallion
decanters would be something like this
raining cats and dogs so you just say
that but it happened that I was in India
so for me it's not that I'm always at
home doing videos in a studio or
something like that no right no I just
go to the street and for me more I'm
using that so you have videos with
Spanish content therefore plus you also
teach online yes so those are the two
the two functions yes
okay and I mean we have a lot of people
who are working on Spanish and they
should perhaps go and visit you and see
see what you have there is there a lot
of interest in Spanish say in the Czech
Republic yes yes that's that's a good
thing when I started living here it was
like five and half years ago I came here
to live I saw that most of the people
say that english is the language they
need to work so everybody studies
English here
almost everybody speaks English but then
they have German to do business German
is the business language
and the Spanish is the holiday language
and I said okay we adjust the holiday
language I mean something they don't
need but in the end they say okay if
they want to learn something to have fun
so to go on holiday it means that they
are willing to do it it's not like a
German they have to learn it
yeah right so the interest is great so
everybody love Spanish mm-hmm I think
people associate Spanish with fun yeah
food travel whether it be in Spain or
Latin America okay well Sergey it's been
fun we did a long an interview in
Spanish as well which is on your channel
yeah and so I hopefully we will meet
again okay sure maybe in Prague I gotta
work on my chair maybe brag I I have to
go to Canada to I have never been
absolutely what do you have here maybe
maybe I'll need Catalan teacher too sure
what do you if we do a live videos on
something on the street I say yeah hello
okay could be nice sure you come here
we'll do a live video yeah okay thank
you thank you very much bye-bye
[Music]